hey guys how's it going happy holidays
I'm excited because today we are going
to be turning my home into a Google home
hey Google who's iJustine according to
Wikipedia Justine ezarik is an American
YouTube personality post and after hey
Google I think you're really sweet you
were so sweet to say that so in my
family we have some pretty fun holiday
traditions number one tradition being we
bake cookies usually my mom bakes them
but since I've moved across country to
California I tried to bake holiday
cookies myself and usually doesn't turn
out very well because I end up
forgetting everything that I need to
make the cookies but this year is
different because hey Google how do I
make gingerbread cookies according to
all recipes sift together the flour
baking powder ginger nutmeg cloves and
cinnamon set aside in a medium bowl mix
together the shortening molasses brown
sugar water egg and vanilla until smooth
gradually stir in the dry ingredients
until they're completely absorb I just
realized I forgot to get ginger so hey
Google add ginger to my shopping list ok
I've added ginger to your shopping list
oh great I once made a gingerbread
cookie videos so I guess while I'm
baking I should probably watch my own
video hey Google Play I just seen how to
bake gingerbread cookies on my kitchen
TV yeah something's all right a lot of
flowers paint out the glow I won't even
roll out you can gently state one single
cookie out of this and I'll be a happy
another big tradition in my parents
house is they love to decorate for the
holidays especially with lights but now
with the introduction of light bulbs
that you can basically control from your
phone you can now control them using
Google home I've got some preset
Christmas lights
so basically this is all I have to do I
just got to say hey Google turn on my
Christmas lights you got it turning 43
lights on hey Google play me some
Christmas music sure check out this
Christmas music radio mix on YouTube you
know that you're a dancer and prancer
this comic stop playing my Christmas
music hey Google can you turn off my
Christmas lights okay
turning 43 lights off hey Google can you
set a timer for 15 minutes for my
cookies okay a 15 minute timer called my
cookies and that's starting now
something else that reminds me of the
holidays is hot chocolate just something
about having a nice warm cup of hot
chocolate let me tell you what makes it
taste even better to be able to tell my
google home to make it for me hey Google
turn the hot chocolate on okay turning
the hot chocolate on the connected to
the Samsung smartthings outlet to turn
on my hot chocolate / coffee maker it's
a dream come true one of the other
really cool things is scheduling in
calendars so this is linked up to my
google calendars so instead of texting
my sister every five seconds asking her
what my flight home is okay Google when
is my flight home to Pittsburgh American
flight 2061 from Los Angeles to
Pittsburgh leaves at 4:28 p.m. on
December 20th so one of the things that
I really love the most about this is it
looks cool it just fits in with my decor
especially but there's also these little
speaker covers that you can get so you
can switch out with any of these colors
that they have available on store
google.com
well that was easy just snaps right back
in
[Music]
so with everybody in one location for
the holidays the internet just doesn't
reach all the way throughout the house
but here is my new holiday tradition
solution whoo-hoo ëifí so this thing
will replace you what what what are you
doing
Oh God my cookies are done hey Google
turn on my Christmas lights
sure turning 43 lights on Google Wi-Fi
basically this thing replaces your
router and it's made for using multiple
devices and I have so many things
connected in my house that this is
really going to be a lifesaver let's go
set these up
[Music]
this thing will allow us to have whole
house Wi-Fi no matter where we are in
the house as long as this is here we're
good to go
[Music]
roundabouts my hot chocolate now that
I've got my Wi-Fi all set up how about
we add some more devices onto this thing
I have been looking forward to trying
out the Google pixel phone for the
longest time
since the day that it was released I was
like I need to get one of these so here
we are
now's the time let's open this bad boy
up hey Google where can I buy a
Christmas sweater ugly Christmas
sweaters Los Angeles is on Glendale
Galleria 100w Broadway in Glendale and
15 miles away just save that for later
so one of the coolest things is you can
get unlimited photo storage at full
resolution on the pixel phone which
means I can take an unlimited number of
photos of my dog and it's Christmas
weather so my sister Jenna and I have
the best holiday tradition ever ever
since I can remember when we were super
young we would always play video games
all throughout the holidays this year
I've got a fun little surprise to
integrate into our holiday gaming it is
Google daydream there's a bunch of
really fun 360 games that you can play
with this pop in your pixel phone hey
Google when's Christmas Christmas Day is
on Sunday December 25th 2016 hey Google
can you add to my shopping list to buy
my mom a Google home okay I've added by
my mom and Google home to your shopping
list can you add to my shopping list to
buy my sister at Google daydream for
Christmas okay
I've added by my sister at Google
daydream for Christmas to your shopping
list
that's my girl this thing's so soft too
it's really nice hey Google Play you log
on YouTube on my living room TV sure
plan you log from YouTube on living room
TV oh here's my controller oh isn't this
peaceful thank you guys so much for
watching I hope that you enjoyed my tech
take on my family's holiday traditions a
huge thank you to the Google store for
partnering with me on this video if you
guys have any family traditions of your
own let me know what you guys would have
done with the Google assistant or your
Google pixel phone or how you guys can
turn your family traditions into
something super tech-savvy
you guys between us at I just need
it will store and use the hashtag
holidays by us I'll see you guys the
next video
happy holidays bye
[Music]
you